being a ceo is totally different uh
a you know we
i was a cto before but being a ceo
it has a responsibility that you need to
bring the food
to the people
and you need to think and there is no
someone that you can count on
and this is a different way of thinking
and full and
more responsibility in a way
um
and but
but i i think that with that it comes
with
uh
the ability to make things your way and
this is what's funny about it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am joined by david dre
co-founder and ceo of anadot
ceo and co-founder david started anadod
out of his frustration with not being
able to get real-time insights in spite
of having access to real-time big data
with anudot he stands committed to
helping companies from digital to
fintech to telecom illuminate business
blind spots with ai analytics he
previously was cto at get an app-based
transportation service used in hundreds
of cities worldwide prior to get he
co-founded contendo a content delivery
network and site acceleration services
provider that was acquired by akamai
technologies where he also served as cto
david dre welcome to 20 minute leaders
co-founder and ceo of an adult how are
you michael
i i'm happy to be here how are you i'm
really excited to talk to a chief
dashboard officer and i'm excited to
talk to somebody who was injured by a
printer i'm going to have to hear that
that story a little bit
and and i want to hear also the story of
how you
were working at a gas station in middle
school and from being in a gas station
and working the gas station to being the
chief technology officer of one of my
favorite companies get which i use like
15 times a day to now being the
co-founder and ceo of of antidote and
helping businesses monitor autonomously
their their revenues customer experience
and everything in between david who are
you you're a man of many hats
hi how are you michael so uh yes uh if
you talked about the gas station
uh
so i will tell you
it was a nice story
i wanted a radio double cassette at that
time if you remember i don't know if you
remember you are too young
for that but i really wanted a radio
double cassette and my parents told me
you want you need to work i was looking
for a job
i would say that since then probably i
have this kind of entrepreneurship
mentality
and i found
this place
and i was actually uh in charge of
feeling gut station for
gas for
army
vehicles it will separate the gas
different gas than the regular one yeah
interesting times uh since then
so uh
regarding uh
being the city of get
actually it was uh
many many
water under the bridge until i arrived
to that
situation i was many years
in the air force in technology
i studied a technion institute
uh bsc and then i was chief architect
developer chief architect of a company
named contact
great company that i remember for
good memories
and after that uh i started my first uh
a venture with
contendo around cdn
sold it to akamai we sold it to akamai
after four and a half years it was
really a good success
and later on i was i took a break
um and then
i decided to be a kind of consultant
my friend that was at that time vp of
our leader
tell me david and steph of just surfing
into the beach let's surf into also the
internet with us
so yeah i started there it was a very
interesting experience uh
one year uh
and
people called me they're actually the
chief dashboard officer because i write
always
on their business data always on the
business data
however my frustration was
we understood the the business we
understood the business with dashboards
and you know
it was a long time ago it was seven
years ago
and at that time
collecting data was not i would say
uh the most uh
advanced thing that
you could see in the market
uh at that time uh snowflake was a nice
startup
uh
and uh redchief was
starting to grow uh significantly but
still collecting data was not uh
so uh
well mature
uh and and
what we saw is that the more we
collected data and try to collect data
the less we know about the business
uh and and then i i started to ask
myself how come why
uh
and and the conclusion was actually that
i'm trying to understand that with human
with people with my eyes with vi
uh people that are looking in dashboard
with their eyes
we are not doing something intelligent
here we are just looking at graph
and hoping that we will get conclusion
from the chart that something wrong is
happening all right but there is a
change
and i was saying to myself okay there is
it must be different we need to do this
in a different way
why not
putting a kind of something more
intelligent machine learning and i was
not an expert and i'm not an expert in
machine learning however i say why not
to put a machine learning
that will learn that and we learn at
this scale will not be rely on my my
eyes if i'm going now to
eat something so it will still uh track
and detect
uh and this is how we started anode uh
so um
actually i met at the time i i was the
chief data scientist in hp in israel
and he's the guy behind the intelligent
part
of the machine learning and all this
stuff and i asked him you know is it
doable
so
he as data scientists say of
course uh so
this is how we how we started
and tell me a little bit about the
founding of antidotes a serial
entrepreneur with the with great success
from from before
working as a
executive technology officer in other
companies
you know seeing the world in a different
light coming back from
you know from from sort of a break but
not really great because during that
break you also got you were you were
investing in some of the most amazing
companies like papaya global
but what you know what is it like
then going back to the drawing board
sitting in a room with the first three
four people and going on this whole
adventure again together
for me it was uh i will say uh very
exciting
first of all
when i created this startup
i say to myself that this time i want to
make it
uh
in a bit different way in a different
culture
and i'm happy to
to see that
uh this dna that i put in this company
uh as a has been a success
uh people are coming i'm very happy
uh we are trying to build a company
in an environment without uh you know
crazy stress
and and to to enjoy from what we are
doing
and this is amazing i'm enjoying from
every minute that i i'm here in the
company uh i can tell you that when we
started
it was uh like like a new baby
you have the first baby you are very
excited
and you have the second and it's uh not
uh
not less excited than the first one and
it was a real
uh really an amazing uh
an amazing experience i will tell you
more than that that this time i was a
ceo
and being a ceo is totally different uh
a you know we
i was a cto before but being a ceo
it has a responsibility that you need to
bring the food
to the people
and you need to think and there is no
someone that you can count on
and this is a different way of thinking
and full and
more responsibility in a way
um
and but
but i i think that with that it comes
with
uh
the ability to make things your way and
this is what's fun about it
i love it going back to business
intelligence making decisions not by
humans but by computers
you know where
painting a picture of the landscape
around today you know with businesses
that are customers of an adult how does
another go in and change the way
decisions are being made on a business
level whether it's on the observability
level or whether it's on the you know
actionability level
okay so today if you look at the typical
companies most of them are becoming
what we call data driven businesses
uh if you look at
all the segments all the vertical from
gaming edtech fintech
banks
telcos all of them have the same
principle they all are going towards
collecting
huge amount of data and trying to be as
much
as possible efficient
on the data on the business data that
they are collecting
now in all these companies you will see
of course all kinds of visualization a
blow looker whatever all kind of
visualization tools
to understand
uh what we like to call the what what is
happening uh and then
you try to understand whenever something
interesting is happening you try to
investigate you try to drill down in the
data maybe to export it to csv file and
let me give you an example because i i i
think that an example can can it's it's
uh
worth
1000 words so
imagine that you're an e-course and you
now are selling thousands of products a
successful e-commerce all over the world
people are very happy buying from you
and now you want to track your business
you want to say that to see that
everything in every hour is is correct
is working uh as planned
so what you will do you will track the
revenues you will trade the number of
purchase in every country right and then
you will say okay but let's let's check
also not in just by country but let's
check it also
by devices maybe in ios i'm selling more
maybe in android and so on and then if
you take all this combination of
thousands of products in dozens of
countries and dozens of
devices or even more
you will see that it's impossible to
trade and we're talking about
two kpis maybe orders and revenues and
now you ask yourself how can you track
it
so what usually people are doing they
will say okay let's focus on the most
important kpi
but the main problem
is that
in the needle of the haystack if you are
collecting the number of sales europe
revenue drop that you have over there
you are com accumulating them over the
year we are talking about millions
millions of dollars that are there
without any way to look at that in in
any way
uh and this is what exactly anode is
doing and anode is going to the needle
in the a stack to the uh
bottom of the iceberg looking at all the
data analyzing all the data
analyzing when are the holy days if now
you have a spike is it because black
friday or because a a
massive campaign
if now you have a drop in sales is it
because your competitor maybe uh did a
campaign and your audience moved to
there or it is it because you have a bug
in the new uh application that you
cannot buy anymore and people are not
buying and and now you have a drop in
that sales so i give you an example in
e-commerce but the same happen in
fintech like in transaction the same
happened in gaming in in-app purchase in
daily active users and all the kpi that
those companies are collecting
do
do companies get it immediately do they
get the problem do they get the
the way that antidote is thinking
through giving them a solution because
you know transitioning from human
oriented you know creating dashboards i
mean i remember you know talking to a
lot of people like one of my professors
from stanford was the founder of tableau
and i remember talking about how to get
people to transition their train of
thought from excel to these dashboards
you are the chief dashboard officer how
are people how receptive are people to
this idea
that now algorithms are going to be able
to to give them
information that you know their
employees may not be able to
so uh
excellent question i will say that uh
users get that
more than let's say when we started for
sure
from two reasons one
we didn't explain it very well at that
time and now we are explaining it much
better
and two
i will say that
the market is more mature
when you see this evolution
of snowflake that become an amazing
company 98 billion dollar revenue you
see data breaks 50 billion dollar
revenue huge success
and now the data become more and more
mature
you see more and more data ops phenops
you you see more business ops titles and
this is where the market is going the
market want to know immediately what is
happening there in my business
and now when you tell them that you have
a solution that can analyze understand
your anomalies forecast your revenues
then they understand it much better than
than before
more than that
the way that we convince usually is to
say you know don't believe the ai
because there is a lot of skepticism in
the ai i can understand why by the way
because there were so many solutions
that
say that you know there was a kind of ai
buzz and the problem is that when you do
a relay
now how to convince that you are not
just above
now what we say okay don't believe
uh to to what i'm saying just bring us
the data
bring us the historical data that you
have
and we will find
all the money that you are living there
millions of dollars that you are living
there for years and we are able to find
and to detect you and this is how we do
usually a plc with historical data and
we build the product in a way that you
can inject historical data
bring the value and then go live with it
with the product
amazing david take me back a little bit
in time
as a kid elementary school middle school
while you are working at the gas station
what's what sparks your curiosity you
know what fascinates you
you really as a kid whether it's in the
sciences and the humanities in the world
what really gets your brain going
first of all i i will tell you i i was
born in france okay i mean i'm speaking
france i was born in france and i
remember myself
uh since i was a very little kid in
technology i i really liked electronic
at that time
i was exposed very late
uh
to to computers and programming i we
didn't have we were not a reach uh let's
say uh
a
family it was not like today
that every uh every uh kid have uh a
laptop a a an iphone uh an ipad and so
on so we were quite modest
uh i didn't have a computer at all
uh but with the time we
i was
exposed to more computer but at the
beginning to electronic and all the time
i was very fascinated about
that area
i can tell you a secret that i'm a i'm a
kind of
soccer player i was a soccer player okay
i am a soccer player that
played with the most
tough you know people in the in the
society
uh
and in parallel i was a nerd in
electronic and and computer so this
mixture is a is a bit strange
um
and
you know when i was
13 i built a radio
transmitter that i could speak and
people could listen in the radio so i
was treating my
my family that i i spoke to the radio
all kind of uh
a
trick like that and um yeah it was uh
it was a funny because at that time it
was you know to
i remember that i wrote a small program
that
uh
song you know sing a song
i think it was pascal or something like
that
and i sing a song to my mother and look
what i created for you and you know nerd
stuff like that
david i love it i love the journey i
love
you know the the retrospective looking
back at yourself and the things that you
care about and how you view the world
and how businesses should view the world
and you know the approach from you know
from being chief dashboard officer to
what you're doing today and you know the
way that you're going through the po
season that you're proving you know what
the product can do and and the vision
for where we're headed as you know as a
vertical and you know in general where
how businesses are going to be making
decisions i love it thank you very very
much best of luck
with everything else and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you michael bye